Joe Biden's re-election campaign is in
serious trouble the president is
struggling to deal with the outbreak of
war in Israel and the problems piling up
at home axios calls it quote Biden's
1979 moment and now the White House is
busting out the worst campaign surrogate
to reassure voters Joe Biden is very
much alive and running for re-election
our democracy is on the line bill and I
frankly in my head do not have time for
parlor games when we have a president
who is running for re-election that's it
why are you not 30 points ahead well I'm
not I'm not a political pundit so I I
I'm not going to speak to that let me
just tell you that we're going to
win and I'm not saying it's going to be
easy but we will win you say that with
such conviction I have no
doubt all right Dana yes Joe Biden is
very much alive should GRE jeampier
worry about her job now no well I think
that you Communications rule number one
is you never repeat the question or you
never repeat the negative you don't need
to say he's very much alive I am curious
about happened to 60 60 Minutes has
given Joe Biden two weeks ago a big spot
and then kamla Harris the questions to
me are pretty soft okay like why are you
not winning why do not people well okay
so one of the things happen is they talk
she talks about the poll numbers and she
resp about Young with young people why
is your approval so low with young
people and she says well we've given
them everything they want on student
loans and climate change they just don't
know it but I think that's one of the
things that shows there's this out of
touch component where the young people
can't afford the rent the rent is too
damn high and they are trying to they're
screaming that from the rooftops and the
student loan thing is not going to
actually fix the rent problem and I
think also they might just be
disenchanted with the fact that they
have all said he's just too old that's
not changing I thought it was very
interesting today James
Carville he said that he has been told
by other Democrats to basically shut up
and stop saying that Joe Biden might
have trouble in his reelection so they
don't want to actually say that the
house is on fire they want to pretend
that it's not but the house is actually
on fire all right Jesse you know the
problems are piling up domestically and
uh internationally and but whether it's
Afghanistan Ukraine or now what's going
on in the Middle East um isn't Joe Biden
by funding Iran continuing to create his
own problems internationally yes he is
yes he is and he'll never admit that was
his fault because he said he was going
to get us back to normal and then we had
two different strains of coid for a year
and a half followed up by mandates
everyone got fired and then all of a
sudden you have hyperinflation and you
have crime you have a crazy border and
now you got Wars popping up all over the
place and the American people did not
vote for Joe Biden for this reason we
wanted normal and this is a catastrophy
now imagine you're Joe Biden and you're
sitting at the Delaware house and you're
next to Hunter and you watch football
all of a sudden 60 Minutes comes on
that's why everybody watches 60 Minutes
on Sunday because it's just after
football and it comes on and you see CA
you're like oh what is she gonna say I'm
alive thanks kamla that's not really the
best you can do because remember the
last thing she said they asked her about
this a month ago and she goes I'm ready
I'm ready to take over and everybody was
like you know what that you looked a
little too ready so now she's like he's
alive and that I mean that's like the
way a mortician talks about people dead
or alive and all Democrats see Joe Biden
like this there's no varying levels of
performance he's either breathing or
he's not breathing and that's because
they have no bench and that's because a
lot of people in the White House judge
enjoy Joy having a diminished president
that they can manage behind the scenes
oh yeah well the foreign minister from
Iran uh was given a Visa and came to the
UN and talked about pretty much
threatened us and when he was asked on
CNN about it um he wouldn't answer the
question um is it any wonder that they
think we'll wreak if they can come here
and threaten us well I should point out
that the leader of Iran gets a Visa
under all Administration so Republican
presidents have let him come and
democratic presidents have let him come
and there have been various protests but
that's not some weakness on Joe Biden's
front um I agree that this is definitely
a crisis moment I don't know if we're at
1979 levels um but it's incredibly
disheartening and it and it's tough to
handle for everybody I think that the
focus of this interview was really on
her foreign policy work and you notice I
kept talking about she's been to 19
countries she's met with over a hundred
leaders I did think in terms of hard
push back he wanted her about the Border
he said you know you're supposed to be
the borders are and that's a complete
disaster um the you know Joe Biden is
alive obviously they need a smoother
message about that but it is interesting
to watch Dean Phillips who is the
recently declared Congressman he's
trying to make a Democratic primary out
of this and he doesn't have anything to
run on he's made that clear I think Joe
Biden did a great job but I'm 54 years
old and he's 80 years old this is really
just a generational issue and I wonder
if that is sparking more of this
conversation amongst people um and I
would obviously push back on Jesse about
we have no bench if it was an Open
Primary you would have Gavin Newsome in
there you would have Gretchen Whitmer in
there you would have Mitch Landrew in
there a lot of people who are very very
qualified for that so uh if it isn't a
an Open Primary I mean why isn't it an
Open Primary you know are they
totalitarian in the Democrat Party I
think they're planning on a big day with
they all come out at once that way they
can all handle the pressure that's my
opinion Jessica I I don't think anyone
who's been in politics has ever thought
of that before I love kamla declaring
that Biden is alive that's not a low bar
that's a no bar uh it's the brf bar I
mean I think that he should walk around
with a little thing around his neck that
holds a mirror to his mouth just so we
know he's alive bottom line there is no
there there our country feels headless
we know that but we're buried in our
smartphones becomes less and less
important to see the president because
we're so inundated with all this stuff
coming at us but now we're in a time of
Wars not war but
Wars you got to pay attention now
because things are going bad again
Trump's tweets might have injured your
ego but they didn't lead to Wars and
inflation an open border and crime we
need a realization that the president is
your agent he's your lawyer he's not
your pal imagine Joe representing you in
court he'd be more more likely to share
a dirty joke with the jury than actually
defend you right Trump was the perfect
agent or the perfect lawyer and that he
aggressively makes the world's terms bow
to your terms out of Simply wearing you
down and driving you crazy drove
everybody crazy but it worked which is
why I have to call out the selfishness
the incredible selfishness of so many of
my peers my respectful peers in media in
the entertainment world who put their
temporary mental Health above everything
else including World Peace you know they
they they started at 2015 with Trump as
a big mean jerk and then they built this
big hysteria Laden Castle on top of it
which made them feel better but it made
the world worse I'm not I'm ready to
accept
apologies I don't think they're getting
any FYI yeah okay up next is Hunter
Biden about to get subpoena by
Republicans hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analyses
you will not get it anywhere
else